خبر على شبكة سي إن إن وزير الخارجية الأردني
يقول إن المستشفى المتنقل في
غزة قد تعرض للقصف أريد إحضار
وزيرة الخارجية الأردنية إيمان الصفدي
التي تتحدث على الهاتف مع وزير الخارجية فقط
أعطنا فكرة عما
حدث بالضبط ماذا يمكنك أن
تخبرنا أقصد  حسنًا أساسًا أه في وقت متأخر من
بعد الظهر أه أه هرع طاقم المستشفى الميداني
إلى قسم الطوارئ حيث
رأوا أه عددًا من الفلسطينيين يحملون
جرحى أه أه أشخاص وعندما
وصل طاقمنا إلى غرفة الطوارئ أه
أصيبوا مرة أخرى وحوالي سبعة من طواقمنا
الطبية  جلس هناك جرحى العديد من
الفلسطينيين الآخرين
قتلوا وأصيبوا للأسف أه لذلك
وقع الهجوم لأنهم أه يحاولون
تقديم المساعدة لأحد الأشخاص الذين أه
جلبهم فلسطينيون آخرون أه أه
إليهم أوه يبدو أننا فقدنا للحظة أريد
فقط أن  تأكد جيدًا من أنك لا
تزال معنا، يبدو أن الاتصال
ضعيف تمامًا، حسنًا، تفضل، تفضل، كنت
تقول متى
حدث الهجوم وأنك كنت
تتحدث عن
المرضى، نعم حوالي الساعة 5:30 بتوقيت غزة، فريقنا
الطبي  هرع الموظفون إلى
الطوارئ أه ردا على جلب
الفلسطينيين جرحى أه
عند وصول أهلنا إلى
مدخل الطوارئ أه أصيبوا وأه استشهد سبعة من
أهلنا أه 10 آخرين
أصيب عشرات الفلسطينيين
وقتل أه الهجوم  من الواضح أن اه اه كان
جزءًا من الحرب الشاملة التي نراها اه
مستمرة في غزة وأه
اه مرة أخرى اه اه من
غير المفهوم أن اه اه الناس
يحاولون تقديم اه مساعدة طبية يريدون أن
يصاب الناس أيضًا، هل يمكنك تقديم اه اه
لنا حاسة أه يا وزير كم من شخص
استشهد كم جريح كم جريح
أعتقد أن هذا مهم حقا إذا كان
لديك إحساس بذلك من
فريقك نعم شعبنا كما قال
سبعة جرحى وعشرات من الفلسطينيين
يعني أه المرة الماضية  لقد تحدثت أن شعبنا
يعالج أيضًا حوالي 200 فلسطيني
أه لذا فهو وضع متطور أه لقد
حصلنا على المعلومات من شعبنا أه أه أه
في الميدان كما تعلمون هذا
المستشفى ربما يكون أحد
المستشفيات الوحيدة المتبقية في حب غزة
في غزة منذ
2009 أه أه الخدمات التي تقدمها أمر
حيوي وأه واضح أننا
نطالب بإجراء تحقيق في ما
يحدث لنرى ما هو الإجراء القانوني الذي
سيتم اتخاذه ولكن مرة أخرى الموضوع الآن أه
هو التأكد من
استمرار المستشفى في العمل  يستمر العمل في أه
تقديم المساعدة للأشخاص المحتاجين أه
ولهذا السبب نواصل عمليات
الإنزال الجوي التي تزودهم
بالإمدادات أه على مدار الأسبوع أه لذلك
هذا هو ضخامة التحدي الذي
يواجهونه
أه سنحتفظ بهذا المستشفى  هناك
لأنه كما قلت هو الملاذ الأخير
لأه آلاف الفلسطينيين في تلك
المنطقة التي جعلتها الحرب الإسرائيلية
خالية من أي منشأة طبية أخرى